in the Ohio town where Kathleen bursford
has lived all 93 years of her life a
dark plume of burning chemicals filled
the sky on Monday leaving a smell of
toxins still hanging in the air I never
saw anything like it and I probably
never will but I'm happy about that it's
not maybe never happen again the
Christian House Assisted Living Center
where bursford lives is near the
derailment site staff moved 18 patients
to a hotel when police ordered an
evacuation over the weekend it's two to
a room because there's two beds we'll
take what we can get now the evacuation
order has been lifted but owner Karen
Christian says she remains skeptical
about returning I'm worried about what's
in my duck system what's in my furnace
filters what what seeped in through the
old building cracks what's in my water
you know am I going to let them drink
water that I don't have tested and that
I don't know is fine government
scientists say tests show the air is now
safe to breathe they say during the burn
off chemicals did contaminate streams
killing some fish but did not appear to
impact drinking water we understand that
this incident caused an interruption and
inconvenience
in our
in all of our lives
however we came together as a community
and put Safety First avoiding what very
well could have been a tragedy of Epic
Proportions 84 year old Gladys King is
still worried but I think the older
people it's going to be affected I've
had pneumonia twice and I'm sure it's
going to affect my lungs for now she and
the other nursing home residents will
remain at the hotel the railroad company
Norfolk Southern has covered costs thus
far I know they're not going to take us
back until it's totally safe that the
town is totally safe even
and now there's concerns that the
chemicals may have leaked into the Ohio
River a major Waterway connected to the
derailment area by about 25 kilometers
of small streams at least one down River
Community has switched to an alternative
water source as a precaution as fears
grow of the contaminants spread
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Beaver
County Pennsylvania